ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today is the day we've
all been waiting for.
We've come to the last lecture
of our course, and it's, I
think, a rather satisfying
lecture today, not just
because it is the last one,
but content-wise too.
Today we're going to
talk about uniform
convergence of series.
Remember, a series can be
viewed as a sequence of
partial sums, and consequently
our discussion on uniform
convergence applies here.
And what we're going to do--
you see, again, it's
the same old story.
Now that we know what the
concept means, is there an
easy way to tell when we
have the property?
And I figure again that, this
being the last lecture, I
should give you some big
names to remember.
And name-dropping-wise, I come
to our first concept today,
which I call--
I don't call it that.
It's named the Weierstrauss
M-test.
The Weierstrauss M-test is a
very, very convenient method
for determining whether a
given series converges
uniformly or not.
By the way, let me just
make one little aside.
Instead of saying the sequence
of partial sums converges
uniformly to the infinite
series, we usually abbreviate
that simply by saying, the
infinite series is uniformly
convergent.
Let me just say that
one more time.
If I say that the series is
uniformly convergent, that's
an abbreviation for saying that
the sequence of partial
sums converges uniformly
to the series.
But at any rate, let me now
go over the so-called
Weierstrauss M-test with you.
It's a rather simple test.
I will give you both the proof
of the test and some
applications of it.
The test simply says this--
and this is where the name
M-test comes from.
See, because you put an
'M' in over here.
If I put a 'C' over here, they
probably would have called it
the Weierstrass C-test.
But the idea is this.
Suppose that the series,
summation 'n' goes from 1 to
infinity, capital
'M sub n', is a
positive convergent series--
this is going to be sort of
like the comparison test--
and that the absolute value of
''f sub n' of x' is less than
or equal to 'M sub n' for each
'n' and for each 'x' in some
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
Then if this condition is
obeyed, the sequence of
partial sums--
some 'k' goes from 1 to 'n',
of ''f sub k' of x'--
converges uniformly to its limit
function, namely what we
call the series 'n' goes from
1 to infinity, ''f sub n' of
x', on the interval
from 'a' to 'b'.
See, in other words, if I can
get this kind of a bound on
what's going on, where these
form the terms of a positive
convergent series, then this
series converges uniformly.
Now, again, let me outline
the proof.
Once again, let me remind you
all of these proofs are done
rigorously and also with
supplementary wording in the
notes, so that you can pick this
up again if you missed
the high points in
the lecture.
You see, to prove convergence
in the first place, I
have to show what?
That the sequence of partial
sums can be made to differ
from this limit, which I call
'f of x', by as small an
amount as I want, just by taking
'n' sufficiently large.
And the way I work this thing
is I say, OK, let's take a
look at this difference.
Well, remembering that another
name for 'f of x' is the limit
of this thing as 'k' goes from
one to infinity, I just
substitute this in place
of 'f of x'.
I then get this.
And now you see, if I subtract
the first 'n' terms from this
infinite series, what's left
is all the terms in the 'n
plus first' on.
In other words, that this is in
turn equal to the absolute
value of the summation, 'k'
goes from 'n plus 1' to
infinity, ''f sub k' of x'.
Again, don't be upset by the
'k's replacing the 'n'.
Remember that 'k' is
a dummy variable.
The hardship would be that if
I use the subscript 'n' over
here, I would have a logical
contradiction.
How can you say 'n' goes from
'n plus 1' to infinity? 'n'
can't equal 'n plus 1',
so I just change
the subscript here.
At any rate, if I now invoke
the triangle inequality for
absolute values--
namely, that the absolute value
of a sum is less than or
equal to the sum of the
absolute values--
I then get that the thing that
I'm investigating is less than
or equal to the sum, 'k' goes
from 'n plus 1' to infinity,
absolute value ''f
sub k' of x'.
Now, remember what the
Weierstrass condition was.
It was that for each 'k', the
absolute value of ''f sub k'
of x', for all 'x' in my
interval, was less than or
equal to 'M sub k'.
So I can now go from
here to here.
But what do I know about the
series summation, 'M sub k'?
I know that that's a positive
convergent series.
In particular, because it's
convergent, that means that
the tail end-- meaning from
'n plus 1' to infinity--
that sum can be made smaller
than any prescribed epsilon,
smaller than any given epsilon,
simply by picking 'n'
sufficiently large.
See, in other words, I can make
this difference less than
epsilon for 'n' sufficiently
large.
And here's the key step.
Since 'M sub k' does not depend
on 'x', this inequality
was done independently
of the choice of 'x'.
You see, in other words, not
only do I have that this
converges to this, but since
this was done independently of
the choice of 'x', this is
uniform convergence.
And maybe I should write that
down, because that's important
to remember, that this is
independently of 'x'.
That's what makes the
convergence uniform.
Well, let's continue on, I
think, by means of an example
might come in handy now.
I think after you do any of
these abstract things, I think
a nice example shows what's
coming off very nicely.
And so I very creatively
call this 'An Example'.
Let's look at the following
series.
'cosine x' plus 'cosine '4x over
4' plus et cetera 'cosine
''n squared x' over 'n
squared'', where 'n' is the
number of the term over here.
For example, the third
term would be 'cosine
9x' over 9, et cetera.
And I now want to look at
the limit function here.
See, is this a convergent
series?
Is it absolutely convergent?
Is it uniformly convergent?
What is it?
And here's how the Weierstrauss
M-test works.
We look at the absolute value
of the term making up this
particular series.
See, the absolute value of
''cosine 'n squared x'' over
'n squared''.
Now, let's take a
look at this.
Since 'n' is an integer, 'n
squared' is positive, so the
absolute value of 'n squared'
is still in squared.
Since the cosine has to be
between minus 1 and 1, the
magnitude of the cosine,
regardless of the value of 'n
squared x', is less than
or equal to 1.
In particular, then, the
absolute value of ''cosine 'n
squared x'' over 'n squared''
is less than or equal to '1
over 'n squared''
for each 'n'.
And I might add, and all 'x',
because no matter what 'x' is
and no matter what 'n' is,
'cosine 'n squared x'' in
magnitude cannot exceed 1.
On the other hand, we already
know, in particular by the
integral test, that summation
'n' goes from 1 to infinity or
0 to infinity is a positive
convergent series.
Consequently, by the
Weierstrauss M-test, this
series here is uniformly
convergent,
which again means what?
That the sequence of partial
sums, namely sum 'k' goes from
1 to 'n', ''cosine 'k squared
x'' over 'k squared'',
converges uniformly to summation
'n' goes from 1 to
infinity ''cosine 'n squared
x'' over 'n squared''.
That's how the test works.
But now, from an engineering
point, the
more important question--
what does it mean?
How can we use it?
Well, for example, let's suppose
that in working some
particular applied problem,
one had to integrate this
particular series, 'cosine x'
plus ''cosine 4x' over 4' plus
''cosine 9x' over 9', et cetera,
the infinite series
from 0 to some value 't'.
Now here's the key point.
And by the way, I just
write it this way--
to get used to the ominous
notation, notice that what
looks a little bit ominous here
is just another way of
writing out, longhand, what
the terms inside the
parentheses are.
The idea is this.
Notice what this says--
this says first compute the
sum and then integrate.
For example, we might not
know what limit this sum
approaches.
Or if we do know it, it may be
a particularly complicated
thing to write down.
You see, in other words, if we
follow the problem in the
order that the operations are
given, we must first sum this
series and then integrate it.
But what have we
already shown?
We've already shown that this
series is uniformly
convergent, but for a uniform
convergent series, we saw last
time that you can interchange
the order of summation and
integration.
In other words, by uniform
convergence, what I can now do
is integrate this thing
here, term by term.
See, 'sine x' plus ''sine
4x' over 16'.
Just the usual technique
of integration.
And now you see I can integrate
first and then
compute the limit.
In other words, I can say, look,
this integral is just
'sine t' plus ''sine 4t'
over 16' plus et
cetera, and so forth.
Again, if you want to see this
from the abstract point of
view, what I'm saying is that by
uniform convergence, I can
switch these two symbols.
Now, the important point is that
to integrate ''cosine 'n
squared x'' over
'n squared''--
remember, 'n' is a
constant here.
This is a very easy thing
to integrate.
In fact, it comes
out to be what?
''Sine 'n squared x'' over
'n to the fourth''.
You see the 'n squared' comes
down as an 'n to the fourth'.
And when I evaluate that between
0 and 1, all I wind up
with is summation 'n' goes from
one to infinity, ''sine
'n squared t'' over 'n
to the fourth''.
And this is a perfectly good,
bona fide convergent series.
And, in real life, you see I
can approximate this to any
degree of accuracy that I want
just by going out far enough
before I chop off the
remaining terms.
In other words, the beauty in
this case with series is that
when they converge uniformly and
you have to integrate the
limit function, you can
integrate the individual
member of the sequence first and
then take the limit as n
goes to infinity.
OK.
So far so good.
Let's apply this now, in
particular, to power series.
And again, let me keep reminding
you, all of this
stuff is done much more slowly
in the supplementary notes.
My main reason for repeating
what's in the supplementary
notes is I think this material
is both difficult enough and
new enough so I think you should
hear parts of it before
you're sent out on your
own to read it.
Hopefully my words will sound
familiar to you as you hear
them repeated in the
supplementary notes.
Let's suppose that a power
series summation, 'a n', 'x to
the n', as 'n' goes from 0 to
infinity, converges for the
absolute value of 'x'
less than 'R'.
And let me pick a couple of
values of 'x', 'x sub 0' and
'x sub 1', such that 'x sub 0'
in magnitude is less than 'x
sub 1' in magnitude,
which in turn is
less than 'R' in magnitude.
To give you a hint as to what
I'm going to be driving at,
I'm going to try to prove that
this series converges
uniformly within 'R'.
And I'm going to try to prove
it by setting up the
Weierstrauss M-test.
And I'm going to have to compare
this with a positive
convergent series, and the
positive convergent series
that I have in mind is going to
make use of the fact that
the magnitude of 'x0' divided by
the magnitude of 'x1' is a
positive constant less than 1.
And I'm going to set this thing
up so that I can use a
geometric series on it.
And if that sounds confusing,
let me just go through this
now in slow motion and show you
what I'm driving at here.
See, first of all, since 'x1'
is within the radius of
convergence, that means in
particular that summation 'a n
''x sub 1' to the n'',
as 'n' goes from 0
to infinity, converges.
Since this converges, in
particular-- the very first
test that we learned--
in particular, the n-th
term must go to 0.
Remember, for a convergent
series, the n-th
term goes to 0.
Now, since the limit of 'a n 'x1
to the n-th'' is 0, that
means that for n large enough,
this will get smaller than any
positive constant.
Otherwise it couldn't
converge on 0.
All right?
So all I'm saying there, I
guess, is if this is 0 and
this is 'M', if I can't make
this thing less than 'M', how
can the limit ever be 0?
In other words, if these things
can't get past 'M', how
could the limit be 0?
So all I'm saying is that, given
a positive 'M', I can
always find an 'n' such that
when I go out far enough-- in
other words, when the subscript
'n' is greater than
capital 'N', the magnitude of
'a n 'x1 to the n'' is less
than capital 'M'.
Now the key idea is this.
What I'm going to do is look at
summation 'a n 'x0 to the
n'' where 'x0' is as
given over here.
Now what I'm going to try to
do is set this up for the
Weierstrauss M-test, and
the way I'm going to
do that is as follows.
I look at the absolute value
of 'a n 'x0 to the n''.
Somehow or other, the thing I
have control over is not 'a n
'x0 to the n'', but rather
'a n 'x1 to the n''.
And now I use that very common
mathematical trick that gets
us out of all sorts of binds,
and that is that, since I
would like 'a n 'x1 to the n''
over here, I just put it in.
And then I must cancel
it out again.
In other words, all I do is I
rewrite 'a n 'x0 to the n'' as
'a n' times 'x0' over 'x1 to the
n', times 'x1 to the n'.
In other words, notice that this
just cancels and I have
what I started with over here.
The point is that the magnitude
of 'a n 'x1 to the
n'' is less than 'M'.
We already saw that.
So what I do is I split
this thing up.
Remember, the absolute value of
a product is the product of
the absolute values.
So I write it as what?
The magnitude of this times
this, times the magnitude of
''x0 over x1' to the n'.
In other words, I guess what
I should have over here--
this is still an equality.
This is just rewriting.
The absolute value of a product
is a product of the
absolute values.
Consequently, this is the
absolute value of 'a n 'x1 to
the n'' times the absolute
value of ''x0
over x1' to the n'.
And the key point is that the
absolute value of 'a n 'x1 to
the n'' is less than 'M' for
'n' sufficiently large.
In other words, for 'n'
sufficiently large, the
magnitude of 'a n 'x0 to the n''
is less than or equal to
this expression here.
But what is this expression?
My claim is that this is the
n-th term of a convergent
positive series, namely a
convergent geometric series.
I'm going to to show you
this in more detail.
All I'm saying is observe that
the magnitude of 'x0 over x1',
since 'x0' is less than 'x1'
in magnitude, is a positive
constant less than 1.
Therefore, this is what?
This is a geometric series whose
ratio is 'x0 over x1'.
In other words, as you pass from
the n-th term to the 'n
plus first' term, in each case
you just multiply by 'x0 over
x1', which is a constant.
Therefore, by the Weierstrauss
M-test, this given series is
uniformly convergent inside the
interval of convergence.
You see?
In other words, what this now
means is that we can replace
the condition that the series
was absolutely convergent
inside the radius of convergence
by, it's uniformly
convergent inside the radius
of convergence.
And now you see the question is,
what does that help us do?
And again, this is left in
great detail for the
supplementary notes and the
exercises, but I thought that
for a finale, we should do
a rather nice practical
application.
In particular, a problem that
we haven't tackled at all.
We wern't able to tackle it, but
a problem that we've used
as a scapegoat many times to
show, for example, why the
First Fundamental Theorem of
integral calculus was not the
cure-all it was supposed
to be, for example.
Let me show you what example
I have in mind.
I'm thinking of this example.
Find the area of the region 'R',
where 'R' is the region
bounded above by our old friend
'y' equals 'e to the
minus 'x squared'', below by the
x-axis, on the left by the
y-axis, and on the right by
the line 'x' equals 1.
You see, what we used to
say before was what?
We know by the definition of a
definite integral that the
area of the region 'R' is the
integral from 0 to 1, 'e to
the minus 'x squared'', 'dx'.
But what we do not know
explicitly is a function, 'G
of x', for which 'G prime
of x' is 'e to
the minus 'x squared''.
Remember, we could solve this
problem by trapezoidal
approximations and things
of this type.
We could approximate it, but we
couldn't get a good bound
on the answer very
conveniently.
What I thought I'd like to show
you now is how one uses
power series to solve this
kind of a problem.
If nothing else, this one
application should be enough
impetus to show you the
power of power series.
They are a very, very important
and powerful
analytical technique.
Let's see how we can
handle this.
First of all, from our previous
material, we already
know that 'e to the u' is
represented by '1 plus u plus
''u squared' over '2 factorial''
plus' et cetera,
''u to the n' over 'n
factorial'', et cetera, for
all real numbers 'u'.
OK, we already know that.
In particular, if I now think
of-- see, since 'u' is
generically just a name for any
real number, since minus
'x squared' is a real number
also, I can replace 'u' by
minus 'x squared'.
And replacing 'u' by minus 'x
squared' leads to what? 'e to
the minus 'x squared'' is
1, minus 'x squared'.
Now minus 'x squared', squared,
is 'x to the fourth',
over 2 factorial.
And in general, we see when
I replace 'u' by minus 'x
squared', this becomes plus or
minus 'x to the 2n' over 'n
factorial'.
And to handle the plus or minus,
I simply put in my sign
alternator-- that's minus
1 to the n-th power.
And the reason I use 'n' here,
rather than, say, 'n plus 1',
is to keep in mind that in power
series, this is called
the 0-th term.
In other words, when 'n' is 0,
minus 1 to the 0 would be
positive, and I want the first
term to be positive.
At any rate, to make a
long story short--
shorter--
another way of writing this
is that 'e to the minus 'x
squared'' is summation 'n' goes
from 0 to infinity, minus
'1 to the n', 'x to the 2n'
over 'n factorial'.
Consequently, since these two
are synonyms, to compute the
integral from 0 to 1, ''e to the
minus 'x squared'' dx', I
can replace 'e to the minus 'x
squared'' by the power series
which converges to
it uniformly.
Namely, I can now write
this as what?
Integral from 0 to 1, summation
'n' goes from 0 to
infinity, minus '1 to the n',
'x to the 2n' over 'n
factorial' times 'dx'.
Now notice what this says.
This says, in the order of the
given operations, that I must
form the sum of this series
first, which is not an easy
job, and then integrate
that from 0 to 1.
But the beauty is that, by the
Weierstrauss M-test, I know
that this converges uniformly
wherever it converges
absolutely.
I already know that it does
converge absolutely
for all real 'x'.
At any rate, then, I now know
that it's uniformly
convergent.
One of the beauties of the fact
that this is uniformly
convergent is I can interchange
the order of
summation and integration,
which I do over here.
But this is crucial.
Let me make sure I
underline that.
You see, if there wasn't uniform
convergence here,
mechanically I can change the
order, but I may get a
different answer.
But since this is uniformly
convergent, these are still
synonyms, and the beauty is, if
I just look at the typical
term that I'm trying to
integrate here, that's a very
easy thing to integrate.
Namely, I just do what?
Replace this by an exponent
one larger--
that's '2n plus 1'.
Divide through by '2n plus 1'.
In other words, the integral
from 0 to 1, ''e to the minus
'x squared'' dx', is just this
particular power series,
namely summation 'n' goes from 0
to infinity, minus '1 to the
n', 'x to the '2n plus 1'' over
''2n plus 1' times 'n
factorial''.
That must be evaluated
between 0 and 1.
Since the lower limit gives me
0 and the upper limit here
just gives me a 1, rewriting
this-- this is just what?
Summation 'n' goes from 0 to
infinity, minus '1 to the n'
over ''2n plus 1' times
'n factorial''.
In other words--
let's take a look at this.
When 'n' is 0, this term is 1.
When 'n' is 1, this is
minus 1 over what?
3 times 1 is 3.
When 'n' is 2, this is 5 times
2 factorial, which is 10.
When 'n' is 3, this is
minus 1 to the third
power, which is minus.
This is 7 times 3 factorial.
7 times 3 factorial is what?
7 times 6, which is
42, et cetera.
In other words, what we now know
is that 'A sub R' is 1
minus 1/3 plus 1/10
minus 1/42.
And if we keep on going this
way, the next term is 1/216,
which we can compute
very easily.
What is this, by the way?
This is a convergent
alternating series.
And as you recall from our
learning exercises and some of
the material in our
supplementary notes, not only
does this thing converge, but
in such a case the error is
never greater than the magnitude
of the next term.
So, you see, what I can do
over here is just take 1,
subtract 1/3, add 1/10, subtract
1/42, and know that
whatever answer I get when I
do this has to be exact to
within no more of an
error then 1/216.
And in fact, if I now
add on the 1/216,
I think I get 0.748.
And the next term is going to
be something like 1/1,300,
which means that this must be
correct to within three
decimal places.
And this is the way the
so-called error function, the
table of error function,
is actually computed.
Now I'm going to end the
material of the course right
at this particular point.
In other words, I will leave the
remaining applications for
the exercises and the
supplementary notes.
What I would like to do is to
become subjective for a moment
or so, if I may.
And even though this course is
quite different from a regular
classroom course, I would like
to end it like a regular
classroom course.
And that is to make a genuine
remark to the effect that this
course has been a pleasure
for me to teach.
It has been very enlightening.
It has been soul-searching to
both plan the lectures and the
supplementary notes and the
learning exercises, and I
myself, to coin a cliche, am a
much better person for having
gone through all of this.
Many other people worked hard
with me on this also.
And in particular, I would like
to single out three of my
colleagues for recognition.
Professor Harold Mickley,
who was the
director of the center.
My friend, John Fitch, who is
the manager of the self-study
projects and, in particular,
was the director of the
lectures, and also gave me
invaluable advice in many
places as to how to simplify
the lectures and make them
more meaningful.
And finally, my friend Charles
Patton, who is our electronics
wizard here and kept everything
going from a
technological point of view,
and gave me, also, many
valuable pointers.
Now, from your point of view,
I am hoping that you too can
sit back and feel content, now
that the course is over.
I'm hoping that this long trip
back through Calculus
Revisited has given you a new
insight to sets, functions,
circular functions, hyperbolic
functions, differentiation and
integration, power series, so
that you can go back enriched,
revitalized, and tackle the
projects of your choice.
I hate to see the course come to
an end, but in closing, it
was my pleasure and I hope that
we will have the pleasure
of getting together again soon
to tackle, together, Part Two
of Calculus Revisited.
And so, until that
time, so long.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.